The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
BRIAN SWEATT: So we're the
real time ray tracing group.
And as we like to call
ourselves, Blue Steel.
So one thing you might be
asking yourselves and wondering
from us is, where did we
get the name Blue Steel?
What does it have to do with
this thing we call ray tracing?
And this morning when I was
sitting up and finishing up
the project, I was asking
myself the same thing.
We're doing ray tracing.
Where did we come
up with this name?
So I'm going to give you a
little background on what
Blue Steel is.
The name came from the first
day we got access to our PS3,
we went to the student
center like a bunch
of excited kids on Christmas.
And what did we do?
We created a mailing
list for our group.
Didn't even mess with the PS3.
Just created the mailing list
and sat there for about an hour
and a half, thinking of a name.
And somehow, we decided on
Zoolander's famous face,
Blue Steel.
And it didn't have particular
significance to us before,
but as you'll see, it has
a lot of historical value.
Blue Steel is also an
alloy, a ferrous alloy.
As you could see, we have
blue tempered spring steel
that many companies,
industries, use.
And Blue Steel is also a
warhead made in the Cold War.
But these have nothing
to do with our project.
To us, and for the
purpose of this project,
Blue Steel is a distributed
real time ray tracer.
And Natalia is going to give
you a little background on what
ray tracing really is.
NATALIA CHERNENKO: Thank you.
So ray tracing, there are two
terms that you would generally
hear, ray tracing
and ray casting.
Basically, the idea is the
camera is like the eye.
And from the camera,
rays are cast
for each pixel in a picture.
And these rays, they intersect
with all the virtual objects
in the scene.
When an object is hit, the
color of it is computed.
The closest object
that is intersected
is the object that
shows up on the screen.
BRIAN SWEATT: We should
credit these slides.
They're Fredo
Durand's from 6A37.
NATALIA CHERNENKO: And
ray tracing is recursive.
It accounts for
shadows, positions
of other objects in the scene.
There is reflection
and refraction.
For example, if this ray
were to hit that object
and then reflect
it, then another ray
is cast from that object in
the reflecting direction.
And this can go on for
an indefinite number
of reflections.
These are normally
specified in the program.
Here is an example
of the recursion.
So the three planes
are reflective.
They're like mirrors, and
there are three spheres
running between them.
With no recursion, you can see
there is no reflection at all.
With one recursion, you can see
the rays are reflecting just
off the side mirrors.
At the end with two
recursions, there is also
reflection at the bottom.
So it is a reflection of
one of the reflections.
And this is very
computationally intensive
because for every pixel,
you're casting a ray.
And for every
object in the scene,
you're intersecting
that ray with the object
and seeing if it's hit.
And then if it is hit and it
is reflective or refractive--
so transparent-- then
another ray is cast.
This scene here is a
resolution 1024 by 1024
and recursion depth is 100.
And the rendering time in
our program was 2.6 seconds.
The rendering time for 20 depth
recursion was 600 milliseconds,
and for 10 was 300 milliseconds.
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
SPU [INAUDIBLE].
What would be the [INAUDIBLE].
R. J. RYAN: Many of us have
taken 6A37, and in that class,
we're all about ray tracers.
And a typical scene like the one
that is on the PowerPoint right
now could take up
to a minute or more.
Often, if you were
to do 100 bounces,
I think mine would probably
take over 10 minutes.
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE] you
just to [INAUDIBLE] SPU or
[? one SPU. ?]
NATALIA CHERNENKO: We
did try different SPUs.
This picture, we didn't
try with different SPUs,
but we have tried other
scenes with various numbers.
And we did get exact
linear speed up.
So if there were
twice as many SPUs,
it would be twice as fast.
R. J. RYAN: OK.
So I'm going to talk to
you about optimizations
that we did.
Natalia's told you about ray
tracing, and that's only half
of our project.
The part that we have to
focus on is optimizing.
And meeting that goal
of being real time.
And for us, real time, you
have to ask, what is real time?
If we go off of like, the
American video standard NTSC,
they define it to be around
27, 30 frames a second.
So that was pretty
much the goal that we
set when we set out to do this.
And so we took the code and we
think, OK, we can split this.
This task is easily
parallelizable.
But we're going to have to
do a lot more than that if we
want to get better rates.
So we took advantage of the
hardware that we were on.
And one thing that on
the ray tracing end,
we had to go crazy
with, was SIMD.
Pretty much, the
entire ray tracer never
deals with a scalar value.
We use SIMD for everything.
And in the core of it,
we do branch avoidance.
So we really try not
to take branches,
because branch misses are
very costly on the cell.
So I believe there's
something like three
if statements spread
across 4,000 lines of code
for the ray tracer.
We really took SIMD
to hear in this.
Using SIMD, you can process
arrays of structures.
So we took--
NATALIA CHERNENKO: [INAUDIBLE]
R. J. RYAN: We would trace ray
packets of four rays at a time,
and from those ray packets,
we would generate hit packets.
And then similarly, as
you go down the line,
we would produce an RGB packet,
which is four color values tied
into one.
So at every step, we would
use SIMD to our advantage.
Now Brian's going to talk
to you about pipe lining.
BRIAN SWEATT: So of particular
importance on the cell
is not only what instructions
you execute, but the order
that you execute them
in, because there is
no reorder buffer on the cell.
There is no out of
order execution.
And despite the fact
that compiler technology
is very good, hand optimization
and pipe lining instructions
is still always better.
For instance, with our
triangle intersection routine,
we gained on the
order of hundreds
of milliseconds of render time.
We shaved hundreds of
milliseconds of render time
off of our render time for
some scenes you will see later,
just by reordering
our calculations
in the intersection code.
So it's very important,
especially on the SPEs.
And one other
optimization we made
was the fact that we
coded basically everything
on the SPEs.
Anything running on the SPEs
is coded in C. Not in C++.
And we're not using
inheritance when we do use C++
because virtual functions
have more overhead in respect
to memory, the V table, and
also looking up the function
pointers from the V table.
So these are just a couple
of the optimizations we made.
We'll talk about more later.
AUDIENCE: Just a quick question.
So for the pipeline,
you actually
reordered instruction
statements?
The compiler wasn't very
helpful in that respect?
BRIAN SWEATT: Yeah.
So on that scene, 1024
by 1024 with the spheres,
we were getting,
Natalia mentioned
with a depth of recursion 10, we
were getting 300 milliseconds.
That's with optimized.
Without the optimizations,
we were getting closer to 500
with a depth of recursion of 10.
And we gained that extra 200
milliseconds just by reordering
instructions in the intersection
with optimization level 03
in XLC.
So hand optimization, like
Mike Acton said in class,
is still very important.
And I'm going to hand
you off to Mikey now
to discuss the regular grid.
MICHAEL D'AMBROSIO: So
one of the problems,
I guess, with ray tracing
is that intersections
are very expensive.
And when you have scenes
with n rays and m primitives,
well, you have to generate
n times m intersections.
So one common acceleration
structure is grid.
And the concept is very
simple, as the picture depicts.
You just take your
screen, split it up
into a number of
evenly size box holes,
place your primitives
in them, and then you
march your ray through.
And you only intersect
the ray with primitives
that are around the area.
And the good thing
about a grid is
that it's very
easy to construct,
as opposed to, say, a
k-d tree or an octree.
Those take on the
order of n log n,
where n is number of primitives.
Regular grid is order n, where
n is the number of primitives.
And the reason
why we did this is
because with an interactive
scene where things are moving
around, you need to rebuild
the grid every frame
or whenever something moves.
So we favored this choice
of acceleration structure
because it was quick to
build and easy to traverse.
And now Fish is going to
tell you about the fun
part of the project.
SCOTT FISHER: I was in charge
of building the actual physics
engine.
Our original plan was to
the 6170 well-known gizmo
ball in 3D and ray traced.
And I guess if we
want to show that?
I have it running
on this laptop.
We didn't quite
get it ray traced,
but I'm just going to show
you a little bit of what
I did as a physics engine.
Maybe not.
R. J. RYAN: We'll
get the demo working
and then I think we
can use it later.
SCOTT FISHER: Anyway,
it was basically
a 2 and 1/2 D version
of the example that
was just up on the screen.
Flippers work, absorbers work,
and due to complications,
we never did get it
fully ray traced.
And I guess we'll go ahead and
give you the real ray trace
demo, since we do have
a couple of those.
PROFESSOR: So their actual demo
will be on a little LCD screen
here.
Hopefully everybody
can see the ray trace.
Unfortunately, PS3
needs a specific kind
of digital connection to display
things in the right resolution
when you're writing
through Frame Buffer.
So we can't project it
onto the big screen.
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Can I
do it from here?
PROFESSOR: Perfect.
BRIAN SWEATT: Now you
got to tell [INAUDIBLE].
Oh, no.
Wrong way.
R. J. RYAN: Really?
BRIAN SWEATT: By the way,
he's still adjusting it.
R. J. RYAN: Whoops.
BRIAN SWEATT: Uh oh.
Oh, no.
R. J. RYAN: OK.
We've prepared a
few demos for you.
And these are really
just going to show off
the ray tracing part
of it and the rates
that we got after we
applied our speed ups.
Thank you.
Here we see both
the camera is moving
and we implemented full
scene functional textures,
so you see the checkerboard.
It's generated every frame.
We used no texture maps.
This is completely
generated functionally.
Bump mapping, as you can see
in the large orange sphere,
is also done on the
fly, as well as blending
between two textures using
Perlin noise is done on the fly
also.
Showcased in the center
sphere right here,
you can see both
reflection and refraction.
The sphere is transparent.
It acts as a glass sphere.
So you can see the reflection
of the orange in it,
but also the warping
of the checkerboard
as it goes through.
This is one of the
advantages of-- well,
spheres are one of the
advantages of ray tracing,
because you can use
geometrical equations to define
your geometry versus in
using rasterization methods,
you have to actually
define the geometry
in some concrete numerical way.
Going to go to the next demo.
This should showcase some of
the lights that we implemented.
AUDIENCE: So how many
frames per second is this?
R. J. RYAN: This should
be 15 frames a second.
And let me reiterate.
The refraction step requires
at least two bounces,
so two steps of recursion.
If we were to turn that
off, we would be achieving,
I would estimate, 27
frames a second, 28.
But then it doesn't
look as pretty, so,
you know, what's the point.
You can see-- this will
be showcased later--
but you can see the spotlight.
It's kind of moving.
It's waving back and
forth, illuminating
parts of the scene.
There's also a point light
at some distance around here
that's illuminating everything.
But it's basically the
same set of primitives.
If you are closer,
you could probably
notice that the checkerboard
is fully reflective.
This far wall, you can view
the entire scene in it.
Going to go to the next demo.
This is with the lights off.
So you can get a better sense of
what the spotlight is actually
doing.
If you notice on
this orange sphere,
we implemented two
different forms of BRDFs.
One was generic foam shading.
And then the other
was Cook-Torrance,
which helps
particularly with metals
and other materials like that.
It helps have very bright
specular highlight.
And you'll notice as
the camera's panning
back and forth, the speed
ups that we get from-- we
used little tricks to
glean speed here and there.
Like when it's so dark
or it's very far away,
we stop recursing.
BRIAN SWEATT: We're over, so--
R. J. RYAN: We are?
BRIAN SWEATT: Yeah.
So if there's any--
R. J. RYAN: Let's see.
SCOTT FISHER: Do the
SPUs from one to six.
R. J. RYAN: I can demonstrate--
we actually enabled it
so that you can turn it on
either one through six SPEs
using command line arguments.
Let's go back to the first demo.
If I say just use one SPE, we
can watch it slowly trod along.
And if I were
SHH-ed in, it would
be giving me timing information
so I could tell you exactly.
It's really unfortunate
that it's not, because it's
very linear in its speed up.
Right now it says
500 milliseconds.
But if I turn it on two, it
drops literally in half to 250.
You can get a sense
of that, that it's
moving like tick, tick, tick,
tick versus tick, tick, tick.
And then three, it's
a similar speedup.
And then I'll jump to five.
It's getting closer.
And then when we turn on the
sixth, this should be about 12,
15 frames a second.
AUDIENCE: So you estimate
if you had a dozen SPUs,
you could go--
R. J. RYAN: Actually, it's
funny you mentioned that.
I think it was the Julia
re-tracer or the IRT.
BRIAN SWEATT: Both of them.
R. J. RYAN: Both of them
use two cell blades,
which is a full eight?
MICHAEL D'AMBROSIO: It's
a full eight times--
R. J. RYAN: Eight
cores times two.
So they use 16 SPUs.
The PlayStation 3 do
have certain factors.
We're only limited to six.
AUDIENCE: The way you're
dividing up the work,
each SPU taking every sixth
raster line, that sounds like--
could you improve on the
performance by allocating
the rays--
R. J. RYAN: The issue
there is one of granularity
of our distribution.
And also communication
time on the bus.
We've designed it such that
we can fine tune it in any way
we want.
AUDIENCE: But it
seems to me if you
had a localized bundle
of rays on a single SPU,
you might be able to
do some optimizations,
like treat them as fat rays.
Nearby rays are likely to
intersect the same triangles.
MICHAEL D'AMBROSIO: Choosing
the frosting variety.
R. J. RYAN: The
entire material system
works very much like that.
It actually saves
on computations
based on which rays
in a packet of four
have collided with
the same element.
And if it does, then it
takes full advantage of SIMD
to quickly chug through
those rays that are the same
and then never call that
particular shader again,
because it's already
done the work for them.
MICHAEL D'AMBROSIO: Another
issue, I think, is--
PROFESSOR: Sorry, we
should try to wrap so we
can get through the others.
Any more very short questions?
Did you guys have any last
concluding statements?
NATALIA CHERNENKO: Maybe we go
through this like really fast?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
BRIAN SWEATT: Point
is we had two pieces.
PROFESSOR: Thank the speaker.
R. J. RYAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]